you're you're you're the goat you've had
a rough night of work before right I
have but I'm I'm not that
rough this is one of those weeks now
Hans Kim is five and0 all time while
being challenge I mean he literally is
20 times funnier usually when he's
challenged let's see how he does this
week you guys know the words to the
song how do they How does it
go
ladies and gentlemen hun
[Music]
him thank you guys my name is Hans Kim I
am gender
fluid I am biologically male but my dad
identified me as a
[__] I uh think this lizo story has
gotten way bigger than it should have
gotten I think it's just bursting at the
seams at this point it's
just very unhealthy how big the story
has
gotten just a classic case of fat on fat
violence okay these people they can't
hurt each other they're too patted up
they just have to insult each
other out of breath in two
steps um I like to fly with drugs that's
kind of my thing a lot of people get mad
at me but it's like hey the this is my
emotional support animal okay does way
more for me than your [__] dog does
try snorting your dog it doesn't do
[__] once I'm in the air you can't
arrest me I'm out of your
jurisdiction I mean how high does
America
go yeah that's
[Laughter]
enough Dr Phil coming in you heard the
cat you heard the cat
[__] funny stuff though funny
stuff thank you Dr Phil
no Lisa's [__] she's too fat right
yeah yeah it's like How fat you know you
know save some cookies for the rest of
us am I right yes Dr Phil sorry you were
saying um I I hate lizza all right I
think she's obese yeah yeah you and lizo
uh doctor you both are you're both
always
Phil yeah you know I I respect what lizo
was trying to do but you know know I
just couldn't she was a little too
preachy you know she'd post on Instagram
like hey watch me get in this hot tub I
was like well I do got a couple hours to
kill
but
um all right we'll edit this out I guess
uh but no I get I get why she's a she's
a topical do you always do topical
material hun it's my first time seeing
you live um I usually do a lot of race
stuff oh hell yeah like uh and what's
the best race to put down righta right
now the Mexican are really hot ah it
didn't seem like you were in a race to
get to any punch
lines it was it it was that's at Sam
Talon on
threads it was a shocking amount of
light Jabs I would say it was uh there
was a lot of them I counted 11 but it
was very light like [__] [__] [__] [__]
yeah I did the uh lizo stuff and then we
know we were here we were paying
attention know we heard it you opened up
with the words my name is Hans Kim after
you came out to a crowd singing This is
Hans Kim this is Hans Kim this is Hans
cam this is Hans Cam that was a strong
indication of who is coming out yes I
followed the breadcrumbs back to it
being Hans CM yeah frankly I'm shocked
it's you
yeah the [__] out of here we'll be right
back I mean come
on
Hans how do you feel about that set how
do you feel I mean uh I feel like the
audience was sort of like let's see what
you got yeah and then they were like and
we got
it now that we know what you have yeah
moving on you're always I'll tell you
this though Hans and I've seen a lot of
Asian comedy you love Asian comedy you
were telling me that you're always
you're always a delight you come out
with a with a pep in your step okay and
some sort of STD
Brewing uh and I know that your Fame and
popularity as of late has uh created a
culture of gals that are privy to the
Hans Kim experience can you share with
the audience my new friends here uh
what's a what's a recent experience
sexually that might be some material
down the line for you on stage um I took
my girlfriend to Las Vegas we had a lot
of Hotel sex yeah does a story get
better I just started Dr Phil all right
I'm sorry take your
time
uh what what kind of sex what's your
go-to position
missionary uh I I've been focusing a lot
on her ass I've been touching her butt a
lot
wow yep the black guy likes that
response James Atkins showing a little
favoritism towards that's what it sounds
like
yeah who would have guessed that a guy
like that likes a white butt what a man
wearing a hat yeah
it'll make me laugh saying my mustache
is going to fall
off so there it is another new minute
from Hans Kim now let me remind
everybody that Hans has done hundreds of
minutes on this show yeah it's really
impressive hundreds of new minutes not
easy to do and we're about to see a new
minute from your opponent Hans if you
want to put that mic in the mic stand
we're going to bring Hans back out in a
second as the audience will decide who
had the better Mana one more time for
Hans Kim everybody he's going to be
right
back he's going to be right back hans's
Challenger tonight uh has been on the
show a few times we love her she has
always uh done uh a good job this is
going to be very very interesting ladies
and gentlemen Make some noise for hans's
one minute challenge tonight jamisha
albo everybody a new minute from jamisha
albo here here we
go I guess it's kungpow versus chicken
tonight God
damn I'm jamisha I'm 28 years old it's
the oldest I've ever been and uh I feel
like I'm getting to that age where my
[__] doesn't stay as fresh as it used
to like I can't shower in the morning
and have 24 hours of freshness if I
don't wash my [__] like I brush my my
teeth then my vagina wakes up with
morning breath
and there's no mint for that
H but they've got all types of [__] now
to keep your [__] fresh they've got
sprays they've got creams they've got
washes and wipes I saw some [__] the
other day that was like a Glade plug-in
you just [__] shove it up there
and at the top of every hour it spritzes
out this Japanese cherry blossom
scent
some of you women don't think this is
all that funny man my [__] doesn't
stink shut the [__]
up your [__] stinks I can see it in
your [__] eyes right now thank you
that's my time there you go jamisha Alba
with a brand new minute the old stinky
[__] minute yeah if I had a dollar Tony
for every time I smelled a stinky [__]
uh I'd have like four at least four
bucks
yeah I love it jisha welcome hi thank
you thank you for having me excellent
work oh thank you Sam the great Sam
Talent Fon great same time yeah uh
what's going on this is this is so great
thank you for having me it is I uh I've
been I've been doing good it's been a
while since I've been on thank you uh I
I love it I don't even have to host go
ahead oh no I'm just what's your
Wikipedia page looking like oh my God
that was great very funny have you
considered bigger earrings
yes I think I have bigger but I didn't
want to go too big tonight I you should
have gone straight hubcap with it oh
my yeah player yeah those are black
people love Hoops okay there we go Tony
Hench Cliff everybody that was very
[__] funny you're not laughing the
way that joke should be received that's
a black basketball guy joke and it's
very
funny yeah there's Red Band a little bit
too late with a whistle
okay
yeah okay okay was that John Samos on
the electric
guitar oh no that's my theme song yeah
that's actually the sound of my rape
whistle
so that's going to entice some cool
rapists to show up oh yeah you know I
like to treat my rapes the same way I
get out of quicksand just lay there and
don't struggle I don't know oh [__] too
soon okay how often are you combating
quicksand not often funny Sam yeah Qui
is Quicks still even a thing and I know
this sounds like a sefel bit but is it
it's not what the deal with quicksand
yeah it's not that
fast it takes a long time you're
drowning for
hours and is it even
sand same with what I tell you about
making me
laugh oh I have some spirit gum in my
pocket oh no it's real um so I Hans had
a a rough set last week I said that he
was going to get challenged I didn't
have a Challenger in mind specifically I
was drinking after the show at the bar
here jamisha approaches me and she says
I want my shot I want to go up against
Hans next week let's [__] go you
asked for it let [__] go how do you
feel like wi you heard his set we heard
yours how do you feel like you did I
felt like it went okay my only goal was
to do better than Uncle laser so I feel
like I accomplished you did that wow you
did that make some noise for that
everybody yeah oh my goodness thank you
you definitely did that how many times
did Uncle laser ask to touch your
hair you know this could have been Uncle
laser versus Aunt jamaa I don't
know okay jamisha we got the minute out
uh and now let's bring him back here's
Hans Kim everybody this is the moment
that uh we've been waiting
for five and0 against Challengers uh I
uh I leave it to the audience ladies and
gentlemen how many of you have jamisha
albo with how jamisha how many times
have you been on the show three three
times total that was her third new
minute on the show how many of you have
jamisha albo winning
this whoa it's very
loud two and a half years as a regular
on this show hundreds of minutes how
many of you have Hans Kim retaining his
throne there you have it ladies and
gentlemen he did it again 6 and0 against
Challengers proving that he does better
when there's pressure on the line how
about one more time for jamisha albo
everybody there she goes J very funny
Hans Kim you lazy [__] he put it
together only when Under Pressure I won
the most efficient way possible just
with the barely beater so that's whoa
whoa whoa all
right somebody wants to fill out some
paperwork Hans I think that was pretty
close though at the at the start of her
set I think me and Tony both looked over
like oh [__] and she opened with that
kungpow versus chicken if she would have
held that momentum dude you'd be [__]
right now
you and your Rick shabby heading down
Sixth Street
[__] yeah you'd be drowning in some
rape quicksand yeah remember from
earlier yeah all right some quick
rice I thought it was smart of her to
open with a funny joke I thought that
was I think that that kind of SED me a
little bit you
know yeah then I think the overwhelming
underlying racism of the crowd uh helped
you hun thank you for your racism yeah
wow he even did a
Hitler [__] piece of [__] he went
with the left hand too like oh my God
like he was making a call to Hitler's
Bullpen yeah
wow thanks Sam I thought that was pretty
good it is incredible they're all slam
dunks dog did you do the Hitler thing on
purpose just then no I was just harking
the okay hey hey hey hey hey once is
funny twice is real baby with his eyes
that closed he cannot see what he's
doing so there he goes Hans Kim
everybody still a regular on the
[Music]
show